on to some date ITV News involving the
view so why not bring a camera Madison
who by the way I did not know this until
today has actually appeared on the show
more than any other man in the show's
history 21 time how did crazy right good
times on this show absolutely very
popular well they're having a good time
today the view announced that after a
bit of a rocky year they have been
picked up for a 20th season and our
senior news editor Jennifer Perez was
first on the side picked up for 20th
season the show's original creator
Barbara Walters delivered the renewal
news when she came to tell everybody
season you know we thought it which is
never gonna land it lasted since its
debut the views aired over 4000 episodes
and Counting why do you think you guys
particularly you find work you clip Jen
guest-hosted today on the web stream
after the view hi Jen hi streaming
starting tomorrow on Netflix the views
Candace Cameron Bure
on fuller house you run such a
long-running show as a kid and now
you're on another long-running show I
mean how what's it like to have both
going on in your life we found old